ici à dalle c'est la consternation après
cet incendie qui a durement touché la
zone artisanale de la gare les flammes
ont notamment détruit le principal
bâtiment de cette zone d'activités qui
se trouve juste derrière nous alors pour
faire face une cinquantaine de pompiers
ont été dépêchés sur place
une vingtaine d'entre eux ont même passé
la nuit ici ils étaient encore présents
ce matin pour s'assurer que le sinistre
était parfaitement circonscrit c'est
évidemment un coup dur pour les cinq
entreprises qui avaient leurs locaux
d'activités ici sur place certaines ont
beaucoup perdu et des ouvriers
pourraient se retrouver au chômage
technique
du côté de l' enquête est bien la piste
criminelle est envisagée ce matin la
procureure de montbéliard nous a
confirmé qu'un homme d'une trentaine
d'années a été interpellé il est
toujours actuellement en garde à vue
entendu par les enquêteurs une enquête
qui a été confiée notamment à la brigade
de recherches de montbéliard